on a déjà vu des canoës sur la loire des
kayaks parfois même des planches à voile
vous avez vous déjà vu des surfers plus
précisément des kitesurfeurs dans le
maine et loire
une petite bande de copains à trouver le
lieu idéal pour se faire plaisir
c'est al adha gagneur et c'est tout près
d'angers
être surfeur de loire c'est faire partie
du même nom de famille
chacun ya sa place il y à jean-yves le
précurseur et sylvain l'ingénieur
2001 on a commencé à naviguer un petit
peu sur la loire hacker première l on
n'avait pas non plus un niveau
exceptionnel on débutait tout c'est en
en même temps il n'y avait pas d'école
n'y avait rien donc c'était quatre
copains de la loire qui voulait vraiment
absolument naviguer sur la loire donc on
a essayé les pots cassés on a tout fait
on a traversé la loire à pied en long en
large
on est revenu à la nage on est revenue
en stop long et voilà ça nous a permis
ensuite de vraiment sélectionné aussi
d'en parler maintenant de sécuriser un
petit peu le paysage
donc voilà comment ça se manipule c'est
comme un volant si je tire avec cette la
main gauche elle va vers le bas vers la
gauche
si je tire avec ma main droite elle va
vers la droite voilà commun comme une
voiture et ça se manipule voilà comme un
vélo c'est tout voilà donc c'est très
très simple en apprentissage faut savoir
qu en une semaine
la personne part et revient était
presque autonome donc après nous ici sur
la loire pour leur expliquer un petit
peu comment parler les points de danger
ce qu'il faut faire et pas faire et à
partir de ce principe là ça y est ils
peuvent naviguer